this morning we're getting our first
look at the new book written by an
anonymous trump administration insider
it is not out until Tuesday but the book
already has left to the top of pre-sales
charts and CBS News has obtained an
advanced copy of a warning it's written
by a self-described senior Trump
administration official who wrote a 2018
op-ed about leading an internal
resistance against President Trump CBS
is Steve Dorsey is in our Washington
bureau to tell us what the book reveals
Steve good morning good morning Elaine
the book describes the president as a
complete amateur while dealing with
foreign leaders who thrives on schemes
and is prone to abuses of power it also
suggests he's mentally unstable the book
portrays the president as reckless and
irresponsible suggesting ideas like
shipping migrants to Guantanamo Bay and
doing away with federal judges the
writer says the president's own staff
once considered resigning in protest
they even entertained maneuvering his
cabinet to use the 25th amendment to
remove it vice president Mike Pence
responded to the allegation while the
New Hampshire earlier this month when
those rumors came out a few years ago I
dismissed them then I never heard any
discussion in my entire tenure as vice
president about the 25th amendment and
why would I the author makes it clear
the president wasn't happy with his
former attorney general if I had one
do-over it would be I would not have
appointed Jeff Sessions to be Attorney
General anonymous rates the president
told aides sessions was one of the
stupidest creatures on this earth God
ever created and the author alleges the
president even allowed his feuds to
follow his enemies to their graves after
flags were lowered following Senator
John McCain's death anonymous writes the
president wanted all government
buildings to hoist their flags back up I
was not a big fan of John McCain in any
way shape or form
anonymous also briefly mentions the
Ukraine called whistleblower
saying the president shouldn't seek
revenge like tin-pot dictator Zinn
repressive countries the anonymous
author calls him or herself a senior
Trump administration official but CBS
News has
independently confirmed the writers
identity or the claims made in the book
it is not clear whether the author still
works in the administration the person
first caught the president's attention
with this scathing New York Times column
last year the latest act of resistance
is the op-ed published in the failing
New York Times by an anomalous really an
anomalous gutless coward the White House
called the anonymous author a coward and
the book nothing but lies still it's
selling and anonymous plans that donate
us a substantial portion of any
royalties to nonprofits that support
government accountability including the
White House Correspondents Association
Michelle Wow interesting Steve thank you